before we get started the only reason I
get to be a tip with my staff and the
only reason we get to do this interview
is because of house of Aurora I
partnered up with them they're my
sponsor and they've been great and I
want and that's the reason you guys got
free drinks and just want to give a huge
thank you to them for being a great
partner and so now let's get started
shout out to Friendship we've known each
other a long time yeah and since I first
started talking to you you talked about
wanting to make movies and and you know
learning from the best and this has been
a long process for you and you're
finally at the Toronto Film Festival
with your directorial debut what was it
about this story and material that said
this is what I want to this is what I
want to make think that's it that's an
interesting question because it covers a
lot of ground essentially you know like
I wanted to be a filmmaker my whole life
and acting is this incredible thing in
my life not only do I love acting but
it's this remarkable film school and
I've had all these amazing teachers
whether it's like Seth and Evan or Judd
or or you know Bennett Miller or Martin
Scorsese or the Coen Brothers I've had
all these incredible professors
essentially and what I picked up along
the way was the filmmakers who made
stories that meant something to them
they always looked back on the film and
we're proud of it years later and for me
I really took my time I took four years
to try and tell a story that actually
really deeply meant something to me and
that was you know I believe that hard
work pays off because no matter what
happens 20 years from now I think we're
all gonna be really proud of this movie
you know I want to speak for you guys
but I will be very proud of this I will
be - yes I definitely have questions for
the three of you but I want to do
another question we spoke about this
sort of a little bit yesterday one of
the things about this is that you shot
it
for three yeah and so how was it tough
to get permission you know from the
people paying for it essentially I
believe a 24 can cash shoutout wait for
it can cow right so was it 24 was it
tough to you know talk a little bit of
wanting to shoot it in that format and
how did you pull it off uh everyone was
very this is very film nerd specific but
everyone does not want you to shoot in
4x3
ratio because there are not a lot of
films that have made a lot of money in
4x3 ratio and so i gave a presentation
but the problem is there's only one film
that's made over 100 million dollars and
it is grand budapest hotel yeah you know
that cuz i told you that yes yes you
don't even Frank
no no just pull that out of your ass he
was like ah grand Budapest so definitely
that off the top of my head whole
disclosure that that answer came from
Jonah yesterday we had this conversation
yesterday on the street on the street I
got to also meet some of your family yes
and so I learned it yesterday
I do not own that answer okay Thank You
Leona I appreciate and respect that but
anyway I had to give a presentation but
the presentation only had one film so I
had to put all these like power points
in between different clips from bamboo
grand Budapest hotel as if there were
other points I was making but it's only
just clips from one film essentially
it's a great story but the ultimate
result is our film we got the ultimate
compliment you know Christopher Blauvelt
our DP who's a genius we love blah felt
when we were we were projecting the
movie for a test screening and the
projection issues an older guy was like
wow it's so cool that you found a movie
from the 90s that they're releasing now
and I was like okay cool that's really
great you know and the best compliment
we get is that it looks like a film that
was just found from that time period and
you know for me I hope to never shoot
digitally unless the film calls for it
but what's amazing is is it's not like
an Instagram filter I call it when
people trying to use like make things
look old and it it's just kind of corny
to me and it's really the whole movies
about being really honest and really
truthful and
we shot at how a movie like that would
have been shot at that time period you
shot in 16 millimeters super 16 yeah
right so was that tough to do no it was
amazing to do 16 wasn't the issue
actually it was more than ratio sure
this [ __ ] is so specific for nerds like
no this is my audience your audience
okay you guys care about this stuff okay
great you people care but yeah it's
incredible for us to you know we did the
tech check this morning and we're in
this 1,300 person theater Blauvelt and I
doing a tech check and it's four by
three square ratio and the the guys who
work there are like man we haven't we
haven't projected a four by three film
the festival like they had to do special
stuff to project our film in the format
that it's meant to be shown in and to me
that's like very very special completely
for the three of you guys
what memorable moments from filming
what's like what's like a day or two
you're always gonna remember from the
making the film split days explain that
so you know split days we usually work
through the day and then we just like
start later and work do like a night so
it's either a night shoot or a day shoot
like normal hours or then like overnight
shoot but split is in the middle so it's
like a twelve three to three years so
yeah that's four to four not called a
split drunk when you get loopy after
yeah you just tired cutting you like
trying to do your job well but then
you're starting to get like loopy
because uh you're sleepy and you can't
go to sleep you know you're working but
that was really really fun
it's being like with everybody and
everybody's like it's kind of late like
who jokes get funnier it's like I don't
it's kind of like hard to explain but
it's like when you're at like a
sleepover and you like when you're young
and
there's like something that's not that
funny but it like spreads like wildfire
and yeah it's kind of loopy and
everything's like funny and silly and it
just was like those nights sitting out
there and like we're only I'm like
parking lots and random places and we're
all just together in the night and we're
all just like telling stories and
laughing and I think those are some of
the coolest memories for sure exactly
for me you know I could probably I
disagree with that honestly like that's
exact like that was a perfect atmosphere
everyone who's just just like out of it
but also like just like super into the
scenes I don't know it was everything
about the film was sick that like
remember how funny it was yeah that's
true one of my favorite memories of
being on set was one of the scenes like
to not go into details I don't know if
I'm allowed to but one of the scenes I
was like super intoxicated I was
supposed to be mm-hmm and just
remembering me having to stay in that
character after cut and like in between
takes and stuff and it was just really
cool to like actually be like it was it
was cool to stay in character mm-hmm I
like really had to really try for that
what was that real quick just like that
is like that's a such a great answer
because the great joy of this experience
is watching these guys you know go from
never having made movies essentially
except for sunny had been in one film or
been in some stuff but like it -
watching these people over the course of
a summer take it so seriously and by
like the last scene they were firing
what their rhythm was down and like it
was amazing they had become great actors
and it was just like super moving you
know what the hell was the casting
process like for you and finding these
performers well I grew up skateboarding
so I knew a lot of people who continued
on and worked in skateboarding and then
I
got familiar with like you know met new
people through them that are currently
in skateboarding also and really just
spend a lot of time thinking of people
you know and our friend Mikey Alfred
who's a co-producer on the movie brought
in a lot of people he knew and we went
to skate parks and Allison Jones our
casting director there's just so many
methods but ultimately we found these
guys pretty quick but ultimately they
they these these these guys are so
talented that they stick out so much and
they just are different from the rest
and even if they were different from the
parts or their strengths we're different
from the parts I would rewrite the parts
to these people but man I mean can you
guys remember the difference from like
day one to like the last day of like
your skill level or your you know what I
mean check the gate career yeah I feel
like each person from day one it was
kind of like you know you're watching
you're you know you're just kind of
listening to what's being told to you
okay do this and you know kind of go
about it this way and by the end it's
like actually let's run that back like I
could do it better I have a better
performance for this or that or you just
have a greater understanding of what
acting is and a greater understanding of
how to translate that emotion from a
piece of paper and idea into actual
moment in movie one thing I can say
about that is this crazy because
sometimes the moment would extend into
real life like we would do something and
then after it was cut alright cool we
got it the the moments still kind of
lingered around just what everybody
knows
there would be some stuff that was
serious and after we got it done you
know it's not much talking and laughing
and playing or you know it was something
that's super playful and he you see cut
now now it's time to do something else
that's a little more serious but
everybody's still kind of in that
playful movie like a little bit so that
was a that was a good thing to to see
and notice I was really well said of
like it's on a piece of paper
it's an idea and then you're you're
translating that emotion into real
actions in behavior you know natural way
not just like I'm supposed to be brown
you also learn how to you pick up on
very subtle things that change the you
know just that just change how you know
you don't have to have a humongous smile
on your face laughs and super loud to be
happy and you don't have to be like head
down moping to be sadder you know or you
don't even have to you know be super
like enraged to translate that feeling
of anger or anything like that is subtle
things from how you move your head to
the way you look at someone these guy
who's gonna blow your mind it's like I
wish you could just see the film and
then hear what these guys are saying
because I they bring such emotion and
and humanity to this in a way that is a
major expression of why I want to make
the film well the other thing though is
that you are not only being directed by
a director you're being directed by an
extremely talented actor so it is a you
know I'm curious what is that like
though in terms of when you're when
you're directing you know because you
have such a deep skill set so is it one
of these things where you can almost
show you know like with a facial
expression or how you know what I mean
exactly it's like you could just he
completely understands it from an from
an actor's standpoint so it's just like
it's he just like makes a facial
expression like alright
I mean I never did that facial
expression I think one of the best
things about having Jonah as not only a
director but a very talented and skilled
actor is that he could definitely like
even with you know words and and the you
know the way you set up a sentence and
there's like certain things you know he
made it very easy to translate that I
mean he made it he translated that
easily to us so that it was like you
know he liked knowing that we don't you
know act at all until this he made it
very like understandable
so he brought it so it's like in lame
returns you could do this definition
it's just explaining an emotion and when
actors are in their character I mean
these guys got sewing they're characters
that they're thinking like those people
and all they really have to understand
is what that person's feeling and why
that's motivating their behavior and
they made it easy for me you know and if
it was little things I could help you
know but it was mostly talking for like
a month like really talking to everybody
about who the person they were becoming
and because I find as an actor that's
what helps me the most are the
discussions and the hanging out before
you start shooting so by the time you
show up you know how to live in that
person's skin and these kids knew how to
do that these guys knew how to do that
and you know I think writing is
everything right and so I was so
expecting to throw away the writing and
that these guys are just like saying how
you want to say this is the feeling but
then they got so good it was like we
really stuck to the writing more than I
thought you guys were actually more
comfort
with the writing then improvising but
they got so good that it didn't feel at
all like writing you know meaning like
they you pulled it off like as people
talk and we really just you just talk
about who these people are so your
choices become second nature was there
any resistance and thank you guys for
saying that oh and you didn't say
anything nice so we have nothing to talk
about
no the opposite we read like one actor
and a couple actors and it was so not
the vibe of the movie like skateboarders
I grew up skateboarding and in
skateboarders film each other they're on
camera all the time their personalities
shine not only are they performing their
art form but their person I love I love
skate videos the parts in between the
skating when you're seeing people being
friends and in a community together and
I kind of want to show a reverse skate
video with like almost no skating but
the friendship and love that's in
between those moments and nobody has
more charisma depth pain laughter than
skateboarders I mean there are people
that choose to fall down every day and
get back up you know and so these guys
just have it and they have they're all
artists and to me it was just making a
safe space for these artists to be able
to like create you know just empowering
them like you can do this like you can
be a great actor if you work hard and
they worked so hard that that's the most
moving experience in my life I have to
ask did you come close at all to doing a
different project than mid-90s was there
anything else that almost germinated to
completion or was it always mid-90s no
actually what was it I was writing a
play with Spike Jonze four years ago and
we wrote this play and we did it one
night only and then we destroyed it it
was actually really quite awesome he
directed it but the two of us wrote it
it was interesting Bobby Cannavale II
and John Cameron Mitchell all these
wonderful people people were in a
Catherine Keener it was great it was
really fun
Elle Fanning it was it was really fun
tons of cool people actually that's good
invite anyway no it was one it was one
night only it was at the Met but anyway
the point is we were writing this play
and spike has been like a mentor and a
great friend to me and he you know one
of the things we do is when we're
writing something we tell each other the
story all the time
so every time you tell the story it gets
better because the person asked
questions pokes holes in it and you end
up like having to tell that story every
day makes them the writing stronger and
stronger so he was telling me what he
was writing and I was telling him what I
was writing and originally the movie was
about something completely different but
it kept flashing back to the main
character when he was skating with his
friends when he was 12 and spike said to
me you look bored when you're talking
about the are you look less enthused
when you're talking about the a story
and you light up like a Christmas tree
when you're talking about the kids
skating and he was like why don't you
just make that the movie and so
obviously I was like oh good idea
and now we're all here making
mid-nineties you know and you know you
need you need mentors you need friends
you need you need other writers to kind
of go ah you're shying away from the
thing that's actually painful to write
about and that's really your job as a
filmmaker with other filmmakers is to go
like oh you're being scared right now
you're avoiding the thing that actually
is hard for you to write about and
that's the best part of your story and
it's just getting called out you know
and that's the beauty of like
collaboration on that note I cannot wait
to see the film I will hopefully be
there at the Ryerson tonight amazing
these guys are seeing the movie for the
first time today I would be as well but
it's even more special for you it's
equally special for all four of us I
can't imagine what you're thinking about
and going through right now waiting to
see it is she crazy credit thank you so
much for coming in wish you nothing but
the best thank you again
putting this on awesome Aurora man
[Music]
[Music]